[Music]
according to a case study
on saint lucia by the united nations
conference on trade and development um
saint lucia like many other small island
developing states
due to his geographic
location climate
and geology
have also made it susceptible to natural
hazards
the island is vulnerable to hydro
meteorological and geophysical events
the impacts of which can be severe and
pronounced by the island's small economy
historical information indicates that
storm induced flooding
and landslides have been the most likely
hydro meteorological impacts affecting
st lucia
average annual economic losses
associated with extreme hydro
meteorological events for the period
1992 to 2011
have been equivalent to roughly 2
percent of gdp
or about us 26.94 million
however
singular
high impact events can be devastating
example hurricane island 1980 resulted
in damages equivalent to about 60
percent of gdp
while hurricane thomas
resulted in damages estimated at 346.2
million 43.4 percent of gdp
in all instances
we have measured economic loss including
the contribution of the agricultural
sector to gdp which now stands at two
percent of gdp
in the advent of more frequent and more
civil losses to agriculture
including the recent impact of hurricane
elsa
coupled with
minimal to no insurance coverage for
farmers
building a resilient
agricultural sector is paramount
therefore
based on the financing commitment
received from the adaptation fund and
the caribbean development bank towards
securing this resilience today
it is my honor to welcome each and every
one of you to the launch of the building
resilience for adaptation to climate
change and climate variability in
agriculture instant russia project
welcome each and everyone
colleagues good morning
chair having established the list of
protocol i will adopt same
and
definitely ladies and gentlemen
it is my pleasure on behalf of the st
lucious focal point for the adaptation
fund to extend a very warm welcome to
each and every one of you to the launch
of the building resilience for
adaptation to climate change and climate
variability in agriculture in saint
lucia project
it is a long name
but as the project unfolds i am sure
everyone will become familiar with this
name
we all know that this has been a very
long awaited occasion
and having you here with us this morning
definitely makes the occasion even more
meaningful
we are going through a very challenging
time in saint lucia
and kovi 19 has done nothing else but to
pack more on top of everything else
therefore it is imperative that we
demonstrate to our funding partners
that we are not only ready to receive
the support that they have generously
given to us
but also to give the assurance that the
confidence placed in us here in saint
lucia is well deserving well-placed and
that we as a country we are very much
aware of our responsibilities and we are
ready to deliver
as a designated national authority for
the adaptation fund the department of
sustainable development takes the
responsibility to maintain an open line
of communication with the adaptation
fund
the executing and implementing agencies
here in saint lucia
this is an extensive project that will
have numerous activities
this is not a project that will only
benefit the five selected agricultural
districts in saint lucia
but it is intended to be beneficial
nationwide it is a project that we will
be taking to the doors of all our
farmers
all cooperatives our agra processors our
renewable energy technology suppliers
everyone especially our youth
we take further responsibility as a
department with a mandate to facilitate
and mobilize support to fulfill our
climate change agenda and to ensure that
we continue to review and update our
policy framework that will help us
develop other meaningful initiatives
we look forward to continuing work on
our national adaptation planning process
which will bring support in
strengthening other sectors
honorable ministers ladies and gentlemen
this project for want of better words
have been through the ringer
and therefore we are confident that we
are implementing a sound transformative
project here in saint lucia
the efforts of our technical offices and
i say our technical offices meaning all
the officers who have supported the
development of this project across all
the agencies in saint lucia
their efforts must certainly be
commended they worked tirelessly along
with the consultant who dedicated very a
lot of effort rather in developing this
project
again as focal point for the adaptation
fund we look forward to the successful
implementation of this project by our
agriculture colleagues we remain
committed to support
and ensure that we
implement a project that will benefit
all of saint lucia
honorable ministers colleagues
invited guests i thank you and again i
bid you welcome
ladies and gentlemen
i must begin by saying that it is indeed
a great pleasure to be part of today's
ceremony
we received wood in 2019
of the proposed of the approval sorry of
this project
building resilience and adaptation to
climate change and climate vulnerability
in agriculture in saint lucia
today we are elated to see it
get off the ground
or take wings as the technical staff in
the department of sustainable
development would see
to find its place amongst the strategic
efforts
being pursued in saint lucia
as we seek to build resilience in our
agricultural sector that has been hard
hit time and again
by extreme climate events
indeed the launch of this project is
being done at a time
when saint lucia must demonstrate its
fortitude as a country
as we find ways to recover from the
kovid 19 pandemic
which has eaten away at the economic
social and cultural landscapes
we have confidence that this project
will provide meaningful and sustainable
benefits to the farmers and community
members
in the five agricultural regions in
which it will be ruled out and by
extension to the economy of saint lucia
at large
many of you may not be aware
that this project has its roots in a
diagnostic study undertaken in 2015
with the support of the caribbean
development bank
a study which determined that saint
lucia has established a well-informed
and comprehensive framework for climate
change adaptation
to support deliberate measures to build
and enhance adaptive capacities for
climate resilience at all levels
realizing our vulnerabilities as a small
island developing state
this is indicative of the work that has
gone into positioning ourselves to
respond to the impacts of climate change
and equally important positioning
ourselves to receive technical
technological capacity building
and financial support from the global
community
furthermore
it is clear that the department of
sustainable development
with great support from fellow agencies
like the department of agriculture
remains committed to ensuring that our
policies and strategies remain relevant
we ensure
that they articulate our circumstances
and that there are
congruencies with our call for support
this is evident in the post-2015
undertakings such as the development of
our national adaptation plan
and in this case more specifically the
sectoral adaptation strategy and action
plan
for the agriculture sector
the medium-term development strategy for
20 of 2020 sorry to 2023
recognizes agriculture as one of the key
results areas for national and economic
development i repeat
the medium-term
development strategy of 2020 to
2023 recognizes agriculture as one of
the key results areas for national and
economic development
also
it is quite
rightly recognized it has quite greatly
recognized sorry climate change
as a component of the disaster risk
management
resilience and sustainable development
cross-cut informatic development areas
the nap
process and the medium-term development
strategy
are highlighted here
so that we can be reminded as agencies
of the need to continuously identify
and pursue the synergies
and to certain legislators and to seek
to align our actions with our priority
agendas identified in policy instruments
we must continue to ensure that no
sector is left behind
and that as a small and as a small
island nation
we make the best use of our resources
and any support that we receive
externally
and i think mrs leo spoke eloquently
about that when she addressed us
a few moments ago
so wild tourism is seen as the main
revenue owner for the country
the people must be fed
and local livelihoods must be sustained
by injecting the necessary capital
capacity and other resources
this is the aim of the project we are
launching today
which recognizes that if we do not
address the impacts that climate change
has
on our agricultural sector now
the effects will be irreversible
leaving our food security and the
livelihoods of many at serious risk
the details and implementation of the of
plans for this project have been well
thought out and articulated by various
proponents
and as the ceremony progresses you will
learn more about the building of
resilience and sustainability in our
farming systems
the establishing of agro-businesses and
the knowledge management aspect of this
project
the department of sustainable
development which i have the pleasure of
leading
as focal point under designated national
authority
to the adaptation fund
believes this project will serve saint
lucia well
as it will contribute to our economic
recovery especially in our rural
i'm happy to report if you do not know
that both myself and minister prosper
are parliamentary representatives
for rural areas in this country
we will continue to support the
department of agriculture that is the
department of sustainable development
as they take on the responsibility for
executing this project a project that
calls for strong and strategic community
engagement
management agency collaboration and
monitoring
we are confident that our agriculture
colleagues have long prepared for the
task
and are ready for a well-coordinated
implementation of this project
saint lucia remains grateful to the
adaptation fund
and we are happy that despite their busy
schedule they found the time to share in
this occasion with us
we remain mindful of the conditions of
this grant fund funding sorry we remain
mindful of the conditions of this grant
funding
and wish to assure you
that we hold in high regard your
consideration
the caribbean development bank as our
implementing partner is also with us and
for that we are grateful
we thank you for helping to make this
possible for saint lucia and for working
with us
through the various iterations of the
final project document
we look forward
to the smooth implementation of this
long-awaited
project
the people-centric approach is important
to us
as we continue to serve our country
the project proposal development phase
was an extremely extensive
and highly consultative one
that was well managed
for this
i first wish to recognize the caribbean
community climate change center
who supported the consultant and let me
also recognize the consultant
dr barbara graham for the excellent work
done and the support given to the
departments of agriculture and
sustainable development
as we move forward with this project let
us do so with a spirit of
professionalism
and collaboration
we can only achieve the objectives of
this project
by working collaboratively
no one agency in government
has
all the resources required for success
to be ripped
let us keep at heart
the interest
and growth of saint lucia
the country we love
thank you very much
on behalf of the government of saint
lucia it gives me great pleasure
as the minister for agriculture to
address this distinguished audience
on the launch of the building resilience
for adaptation to climate change
and climate variability
in agriculture
in saint lucia project
the government will be the beneficiary
of
a 9 million 153
246 dollar grant
from the special funds resources
of the caribbean development bank
allotted from the adaptation fund
san lucia like
other small island developing states
continues to be ravaged by the impacts
of climate change
often in the form of floods drought and
hurricanes
the most recent occurrence been
the passage of hurricane elsa
on july 2nd 2021
when the agricultural sector
suffered approximately 35 million
dollars in losses
this project six to enhance food
production systems
and safeguard livelihoods from climate
related threats
as such
activities will be undertaken as part of
three
major components which include
one
building climate resilience and
sustainability of farming systems
through interventions for water security
soil conservation and management
integration of renewable and other
energy efficient practices intensive
agricultural value chains and free
knowledge management and transfer
to improve
adaptive capacities
component one is in perfect alignment
with the ministry
current thrust towards poverty elevation
in keeping with the sustainable
development goals
sdgs one and two of the united nations
this is also reflected in the food
security component
that is now
prominently featured
in the new
nomenclature of the ministry
food security will be more vigorously
targeted
and prioritized along the pillars of
food availability
food accessibility
food utilization
and food supply stability
the key strategy which will be employed
is the utilization and promotion of
climate smart agriculture practices
to mitigate against the negative impacts
on the availability of food due to
climate change
noticeably the project seeks to build on
existing efforts soil and slope
stabilization
being done by the forestry department
under the john compton dam project
and the iw eco project
in areas of millet and fosse jacques
respectively also targeted
our water conservation measures to
complement some of the work
that are currently ongoing
with respect to rainwater harvesting
initiatives
increasing water storage capacity and
enhancement of irrigation systems under
the seven crops project
and the and the banana productivity
improvement project
i wish to express on behalf of the
government of saint lucia
sincere appreciation to the adaptation
fund
especially to the board and all those
involved in the approval process who
ensured that saint lucia was able to
secure his grant
a warm thank you to the caribbean
development bank
the bank and the government has had a
long history of engagement
in developing projects and more recently
in resilient infrastructure projects
under the buildback better umbrella
so it is with it is very exciting to
partner in the area of resilient
agriculture
special mention of the department of
sustainable development
and the tremendous of efforts towards
solidifying this agreement
and of course the staff of the
department of agriculture
remain committed to to further advance
to the further advancement of the sector
now that the necessary approvals are in
place from the fund
and more recently from the bank
i urge all the respective agencies to
move swiftly
to ensure that the necessary conditions
are made
to facilitate disbursement of the grant
proceeds for the expedition expeditious
implementation
of the project deliverables
this project is not merely about
spending nine million dollars united
states dollars rather
but it's about transforming the
agricultural sector
in saint lucia and improving
the lives of our citizens
for the sake of our food security and
continued growth
of the agricultural sector
we must all perform our duties
diligently
and always remember to put the people
first in all that we do
i want to take the opportunity as the
new minister for agriculture
to indicate
that the ministry has the capacity
within
the ministry to
undertake a project of this nature
and i just wish
that the project will be successfully
implemented and at the end of the day we
can boost that we will benefit we
benefited from a nine point one
nine almost nine million us dollars to
help address
the problems that confront us in saint
lucia thank you very much
it is my distinct pleasure today to
briefly take you on a journey that will
allow you to see how this project has
developed over time you would have heard
it alluded to by our ministers piers and
others that he has had a very long
gestation period dating far back as 2014
2015. and so over the next few minutes i
ask for your attention as we take a
brief look at
what it is this project is about and
what we intend to achieve
with this project
so this is according to the adaptation
fund standard regular project which is
anywhere from 10 million us dollars on
honda
we are the beneficiaries here in saint
lucia very specifically the agricultural
sector the title of the project by now
you know it's a long one building
resilience for adaptation to climate
change and climate variability in
agriculture in st lucia we have our
implemented implementing entity the
caribbean development bank
we also have
our national designated authority is
the sustainable development department
our problem statement was in the area of
looking at the agricultural sector we
recognize it contributes contributes to
about 22 for the incomes household food
security and livelihood security 22 of
our population benefits from that um of
course the productivity of our
livelihood is very vulnerable and of
course you'd have hood mentioned to some
of the recent storms like elsa and way
back as
1996 when we had debbie and thomas and
all the rest and of course we've
recognized that there is significant
decreases in annual rainfall
here in saint lucia but in the midst of
this significant decrease in rainfall
we're also having intense rains
seasons where we get land slippage road
blockage we get a lot of problems um
with losses in the agricultural sector
not to mention pests and disease
problems and the likes
we also
thought before the challenges including
incomplete data sets in many cases when
you seek for data related to
problems from
climate change and climate variability
we find that there are missing data sets
and so this project is looking at trying
to resolve
that particular situation for this
particular project it has geographical
limitations locally and i'm so starting
on the west coast as far as schwarzell
this project will cover from schwazel
sue frey henry's ancillary coming into
culisac and of course going across uh to
communities in babuna debara and
surrounding areas
yeah
the project has been conceptualized with
three broad areas and these three broad
objectives include contributing
positively
to the growth indicators
for agriculture looking at the midterm
development strategy and plan that was
developed in 2012 2016. of course we
recognize that the times have changed so
that is also going to be reviewed in
terms of where we're at taking a look at
the the sectoral strategy and action
plan and the new findings that we have
in those particular in those particular
plans
the other area of objective that we have
is to build resilience in the
agriculture sector for livelihood
security through enhanced
adaptive capacities for climate change
and climate variability and of course
the third objective is to build adaptive
capacities
of aggro ecosystems livelihoods to
threats so we're looking at
aggro processing and the likes there are
three broad integrated components
the first component is about building
resilience and sustainability of farming
systems through interventions for water
security soil conservation and
management we recognize that we have
issues in the dry season with
availability of water so we'll be
looking at rain water harvesting among
other things
establishing green agro parks including
the use of solar energy to increase uh
efficiency
the
agropak concept has been implemented in
nearby jamaica and so we have this
country and the example that they have
that they that they've set for us in
order for us to move forward with that
particular uh component and then we have
of course the knowledge management
aspect of it where we're looking at
building up knowledge within the sector
building uh the capacity to to
to respond to climate change and climate
variability i'm going to take the next
couple minutes just to give you
the broad project goals and the outcomes
based on these three broad areas that
have been identified here today
so the overall project goal really is to
build resilience in saint lucia's
agriculture sector for livelihood
security through enhanced adaptive
capacities what we hope to come out of
that the overall outcomes is to increase
the resilience of rural farm communities
increasing farm productivity
water and livelihood security and
reducing vulnerability to natural
hazards climate variability and climate
change of course at the end of this
process we anticipate that we will have
enhanced national capacity to plan
implement climate resilient and adaptive
actions in the agriculture sector to
transform the lives of the rural
population
so this is this is the actual
overarching outcomes and anticipated
outputs
component number one that looks at
building resilience and sustainability
of farming systems through interventions
for water scarcity and soil conservation
we're looking at increased farm
productivity as an outcome
we're looking at enhanced livelihood and
income security and of course we're
looking at
getting access to areas where farmers
have abandoned or lands have been
underutilized and getting those into
agricultural production that would
include doing stuff like getting access
to on one on on farm for water supplies
through rain water harvesting
there will be some investments made in
base slope
rain water
harvesting as well
of course the component will also be
looking at
farmers and staff of the department
being trained
in land management for climate
resilience
component number two that looks at
establishing green agro parks
including the use of solar energy for
increased efficiency and resilient
farming we recognize that many people
are talking about hydroponics and and
aquaponics not recognizing
that the high energy costs associated
with these new production systems is is
prohibitive and so through this project
we are anticipating to introduce some of
the renewable energy systems like
perhaps solar and wind energy to a less
extent and see how these could
contribute to reducing the cost
associated with energy for running these
new investments in agriculture of course
the same outcome here is increased
productivity and enhanced livelihood
security for this particular component
the major investments include uh two
green agro parks established one on the
west coast and one on the east coast of
the island and there will be two house
up certified agri-processing facilities
um that is going to be that are going to
be established under this uh particular
component
and of course the third component which
is knowledge management
which looks at managing the transfer and
building up the knowledge capacity of
both
farmers technicians and other
stakeholders within the sector this is
geared towards sensitizing people in
terms of what
climate change is actually doing to the
sector and the impacts of it and so
there's going to be a gender sensitive
baseline develop and let me say at this
point that one of the terms or
conditions for
the approval of this project is that we
will be rolling out
a gender a gender assessment and an
environmental and social management plan
this is part of the first activities
that's going to take place within the
first quarter of the implementation of
this particular project we also be going
to be looking at rehabilitated
infrastructure creating
climate change learning and
interpretation centers so all of these
are going to be part of this third
component of the project
the project implementation arrangements
so we have the implemented implementing
entity which is the caribbean
development bank
we have our national designated
authority which is the department of
sustainable development
and actually the department or the
ministry of agriculture will be
executing the project does have
a project implementation unit
and i'll give you a little bit of a
description of what is happening in that
particular unit there will also be a
project steering committee um that is
going to be providing
um direction and governance for the
implementation of the project so the
human resources very quickly as we we
continue the conversation the human
resources your the project secretariat
will include a project manager finance
personnel procurement personnel
administrative and executive
personnel and monitoring and evaluation
personnel so these would form the core
the core group within the within the
project management unit
there will be a number of consultancies
recruited under the particular project
including agro park managers agro
processing facility managers
knowledge management resource person
human and and and finance resource
persons
we're also going to be doing a
vulnerability analysis and disaster risk
uh for disaster risk management
we're also going to be getting some
support from yui including a
climatologist and plant science plant
scientist who's going to be
participating in this process as well
there's the opportunity for an economist
and also gender specialists
to be part of the consultations for this
particular project
a number of personnel within the
ministry of agriculture and other allied
agencies will be co-opted and assigned
to provide the technical
and administrative support that is
required for the effective operations of
the project management unit and also for
the implementation
of the project
of course as you would have heard
intimated early on this project is going
to be running for
a period of about four years and we
anticipate that
at our technical meeting that is
intended to be on the 16th of this month
that you'll get more insights into the
financial disbursements and other
arrangements uh for the project
as we speak in terms of where we're at
there has been a finalization and
signing of agreements between the
adaptation fund and cdb in terms of the
management of the funds so cdb
essentially is going to be managing that
fund the agreement between the caribbean
development bank and the government of
saint lucia has been prepared and it is
currently with our aegis chambers
ministry of economic development for
review and for signing off we anticipate
that this is going to be expedited so
that we could get the project
implementation up and running a number
of terms of references of reference
sorry has been prepared for the project
manager gender specialist environmental
and social management plan
these these terms of reference have been
prepared and we are immediately after
this particular event are going to be
sending out expressions of interest so
that we could get persons on board and
engage for these particular assignments
so we're looking at
engagement of a project management a
project manager engagement of
consultants for the gender assessment
and environmental and social management
plan the finalization of the secretariat
for the project management unit and of
course finalization of the project
steering committee and the technical
workshop that we anticipate will take
place in the next couple weeks this
essentially is what where the project is
at well there you go and um we're
looking forward with eager anticipation
um to get off the ground to get the
documents signed and of course put all
the other arrangements in place so that
we could proceed with actual project
implementation so with that let me thank
you and thank uh ps for this opportunity
to give you this brief insight into the
project thank you ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
you